[Music]
the realest podcast in the dunya the
three muslims podcast today we're joined
with a very interesting guest brother
ali
to begin do you mind showing us your
shirt today
for the super halal lives
man i wear this in the gym
every time i go man this is my workout
shirt so bro that's that's free dollar
bro
exactly but i got i got people in the in
like the gym they're like
muslims and
other people they're like what is what
is halal what is super vibe so yeah it's
a dalla yeah
beautiful beautiful and uh shameless
plug right now that's the brothers brand
so check it out insha allah he did not
ask me to do this i did it because i
like the brahmana masha allah i like the
i like the vibes you know super halal
to sister
for becoming a member
yes hit the like button
so let's start from the beginning what
was your first initial thought on islam
if you knew anything about it did this
change over time and how were you
introduced to islam
well
growing up a christian for the first 19
years of my life i didn't know anything
about islam as a matter of fact when
the person inside of prison
uh introduced me to islam he asked me
what do you know about islam and i even
told him i remember saying uh well
you're gonna have to say that in english
because i don't know what that that word
means
i had never heard about islam allah
muhammad quran muslim nothing because i
was raised in a
you know an upper class white kind of
bubble so i really didn't
i wasn't exposed to it you know it was
wednesday bible study friday youth night
and sunday church so i was
you know it was it was it was tunnel
vision with christianity so
yeah
allah so you mentioned that you were in
prison when the brother mentioned it to
you correct
yeah
yeah unfortunately
uh it's up to you whether you want to
talk about prison life and all of that
but my question in regards to life in
prison islam is do you notice any kind
of change between the muslims and kind
of their brotherhood within prison
outside of prison do you think that
there's a different vibe when it comes
to what do you think it's stronger in
prison
this is this is what i noticed as um
being a muslim inside a prison is
um prison is respect based whether
you're a christian whether you're a
muslim or whatever
prison is all about respect that is to
say if
you're you know you're six foot five
you're muscle bound and you step on
somebody's toe that's you know five foot
five and you know 150 pounds
that big guy is going to say amen my bad
my bad because in prison it doesn't
matter how big you are
it only takes this bit of a you know of
a shank to go into somebody's neck i've
seen
people rolled up in the in the in the
dryers stabbed to death with sharpened
toothbrush in their neck you know it's
crazy so um
as far as being muslim in prison
[Music]
i think that there's less distractions
that i think there's less static to deal
with
um and temptations
i think that in prison we're all that we
have so we have to stick together right
and we're kind of all
some people are more muslims
most people are convert muslims the guy
that led our prayer he was born a muslim
so we're all acclimating to our new dean
and most of us like myself are
acclimating to prison i've never been to
jail a day in my life never been
arrested a day in my life before that so
yeah i would say
there's certain elements inside prison
that would that would make you think
that
yeah brotherhood is more strong in
prison but
you know we're limited
yeah what we can do inside
100 if you don't if you don't mind me
asking in your actual reaper video that
you made on your main channel maliki
click did you mention why you went to
prison or no
i did yeah i'm an open book man if you
guys want to get into it
bro tell us anything you want to tell us
about why you enjoy your music
so i mean do you want me to start from
the beginning yeah go for it bro okay
inshallah so um
so i mentioned in my reverb video that
you know i was born and raised a
christian for the first 19 years of my
life
so you know it all started when
my father got saved or he came to jesus
my mother and father got a divorce very
early on so i did the back and forth
thing from california to oregon
so i remember
in the summer time he uh pulled me to
the side when i was visiting him and he
said you know son i've given my life to
jesus
i'm seven years old i'm like
okay whatever when we're gonna play
catch when we're gonna go to the ball
game like i don't even know what you're
talking about
he said well you're gonna know what i'm
talking about when we go to church
tonight so we went to church
and i see people i i walk in and people
are clapping people are singing people
are you know doing all this and people
are crying and
running up and down the aisle and
speaking in tongues some gibberish
language and as a seven-year-old child
that scared the hell out of me man i was
i actually ran out of the church seven
years old that was like
boom you know i i just i broke i just
dipped out of the church and my dad you
know what are you doing you know come
back in the church so that was my first
exposure of
his brand of christianity
so
i came to live with my father um
in california and this is where i was
born and raised
and
i grew up as i like to say like a
christian salafi
no disrespect to any celebrities out
there but it was strict i couldn't
listen to music i couldn't have
girlfriends
school football
that's it and in church
wednesday bible study friday youth night
sunday church i mean i was immersed
inside of the christian lifestyle
so
it wasn't until i was 14 years old where
i really started getting into
christianity i really started reading
the bible i really started to
get into that lifestyle you know the
bible all the time i was reading my
bible every day
so
i went to wednesday bible study
it's 14 years old
and i was just randomly reading we have
like a 30-minute time where we just read
the bible before uh the the preacher or
the the youth
minister starts his his speech on
whatever he's talking about that day
so i look at one one verse
and it's talking about when it's from
the old testament i believe where
jacob is talking about i have seen god
i have seen god i know god i this not
and then i turn the page randomly and it
says
no man could bear the sight of god
nobody no man no being can see god
and i
and i
i raised my hand and
i asked the bible teacher or the the
youth minister
i said can you you know and i'm 14 years
old you know it's an honest question can
you
help me with this this verse that i just
read see this verse right here in the
old testament
yeah talking about jacob you see this
verse over here
yeah
and he kind of looked at me like
so what's the problem
and i kind of looked at but i said
you don't see that as a contradiction in
the bible
here he's saying that he sees god in
this verse but no one can see god in the
other verse you don't see that as a
contradiction
and he looked at me he looked at the
verses and he said hmm
i never knew that that was in the bible
and i looked at him like
bro what
like you're that you're the guy man
you're the you're the person that's
supposed to be leading us and teaching
us and explaining the bible
and he just looked at me and he said you
know i don't know what to tell you
but all you have to do is have faith
and as a 14 year old boy i said
no no i don't want to i don't want to
just have faith i want to have faith
based upon something
something that is authentic something
that is valid something that has proven
something that is preserved
and so at at 14 years old
religiously and spiritually i checked
out i've had enough of christianity
so i jumped through the hoops
like like i said in my video like like
many muslim kids do
they're muslim by name and they jump
through the hoops and by the way hidayah
comes to not only non-muslims
but born muslims as well believe me
check the belief of your kids
make sure that they they even know why
they're muslim
you know uh because a lot of people a
lot of our kids a lot of our muslim kids
they jump through our hoops i have seven
kids by the way and they they jump
through the hoops
uh the islamic hoops
to please us
but there's nothing here and there's
nothing here you're just yeah my name is
muhammad yeah my name is fayyad i'm a
yeah okay
i
ramadan
but there's no knowledge of akita
there's no belief there's no hidayah
that has actually
entered their heart
so we have to be careful with that so i
did that i jumped through the hoops
wednesday bible study friday youth night
sunday church jesus jesus jesus okay
yeah uh-huh okay done
go back home do my thing
so i jump through the hoops
and i move out
and i'm on my own
i'm about 17 years old
i get in with the wrong crowd
spiritually
nothing there uh
no moral compass whatsoever none zero i
was an animal i was a savage i was out
there doing my thing
um
living a life that i shouldn't have
lived
so
that ended up to me getting around
gang members bad people
you know uh substances that i shouldn't
have been taking
and
what led me to prison is
i pulled an armed robbery
with with my friends
now
looking back i i didn't even have
i mean i had a job i had money in the
bank i didn't need money
but i was so
morally and spiritually bankrupt
i did it because i wanted to feel i
wanted the adrenaline rush i wanted to
know what it was like i didn't care i
didn't get the damn about anything
anybody's life i didn't care about my
own life
so we pulled the armed robbery
so after that 24 hours later
police knock on our door
we're busted we go to the county jail
i never been arrested in my life never
no misdemeanors no felonies zero
so
we get sentenced
i come into the county jail with robbery
one assault one theft one i'm looking at
eight to ten years
since it was my first offense
i caught the plea deal
uh
and i got
i got sentenced to 31 months
in prison so i'm
things are changing for me my my life
has changed i've really
there's no turning back in this point of
my life
now not only do they send me to prison
they sent me to the worst prison that
this that exists in the state of
washington that is walla walla walla
walla state penitentiary a maximum
security prison
and so here i am
19 year old kid
entering
the
entering jail for the first time not
jail prison the big house
for the first time
um
so do you want me to go into the story
from here or by all means
okay
okay so
i enter prison and i'm just thinking
okay what i'm gonna do here is is
survive
period i've never been in jail so
something about the prison system that a
lot of muslims don't know is
everything is race-based everything is
segregated
so as soon as i get in you know there's
a black guerrilla family
there's the uh the mexican mafia
there's the aryan brotherhood there's a
lot of groups in there
any rule
that exists on the outside doesn't
doesn't exist on the inside
you go by the convict code no matter who
you are it doesn't matter if you've
never been in trouble
you will program and you will do it the
way that is done in prison
so as soon as i get there
people look at my face obviously i'm
white
aryan brotherhood comes up to me
and they take my you know my bunk and
everything okay you're with us man
you're white you're full white
yeah i'm white
yeah i don't know what's going on so
they take my stuff to myself and they
said here look here's some coffee here's
some cigarettes here's some noodles and
everything because that's currency
inside of jail so
everybody takes care of their own people
right
most of my thin
most my friends were black as a matter
of fact matter of fact i didn't have any
white friends at the time
and
i was not racist
and i certainly was not a white
supremist
but you have to be around these elements
again this is prison this is now no
longer your
life you you can't you can't
choose whatever you want so anyways
that being said i really didn't want to
hang around these people so i i sigma
mailed it you know i just lone wolfed it
basically
i didn't want to be around the aryan
brotherhood
i i didn't care for any jailhouse
politics or anything so
i walked the yard alone
again
i thought i was a christian i really
didn't care about christianity though at
the same time
spiritually morally bankrupt
mad as hell my life is changing i'm just
trying to take it all in i remember
waking up my first day in in uh
in prison
and just opening my eyes and
turning over in my bunk and looking
that
oh my god i'm in jail and
that feeling is is is really something
where
it hits hard
you can want anything
so badly you can want to be free but
it's it's just not going to happen
and for somebody that's never been in
jail
it's very strange
but it's something that you have to get
used to anyway so i i i do everything by
myself i'm doing 500 push-ups and inside
of my cell when we're on lockdown when
they do let us out to jail down to the
yard you know i'm on the i'm on the the
white
weight weight pile with the white people
because you just can't
you can't mix with anybody else i mean
even the guards won't allow it because
they know that there's going to be a
fight or something bad is going to
happen
so i used to walk the track by myself
and just think about life
i think how i'm gonna do better think
how to and simultaneously
head on a swivel prison life is
you cannot relax for a second you can't
relax around your cellmate
my cellmate was in jail for double
murder and a dope case it killed two
people
and then uh sold dope it was a
dope deal gone wrong
so he had been in prison for eight years
and had about 25 more years to go if he
was good
right if he programmed and he was good
this was my cellmate
you can't ever relax
it's you you feel the tension you hear
the tension you see the tension
you can never relax prison is exhausting
on the on the heart and on the mind
so i used to walk the track alone
and so as i walked walk the track
i notice somebody
is a what i think is a white guy has a
he has a mustache
that goes down you know those handlebar
mustaches
no beard just a long mustache i see him
coming from me he's he's cut the track
in half and he's coming towards me
and behind him behind him is about five
black guys
and i'm thinking
they're heading straight to me so i
stopped walking
and yeah they're heading straight for me
i'm like okay here we go
okay this is it this is it it's gonna
happen i'm gonna get they're gonna try
to jump me this is the this is the
chance the only chance that i had to
stand it for myself i may not win but
hey everything's on the line all the
chips are in i have to defend myself so
i stood my ground
and as they got about 10 feet away from
me i was like
you know i got into like a fighting pose
i was like what's up man what what is it
and
the guy in the front was like whoa
no no no no not like that no no
he and he said oh yeah i see how it
looks i
my apology i apologize about that man no
no no we just
we just want to talk to you
i said well does it take six people to
talk to me or does it just take one
person to talk to me
and he said i understand man let's can
you give me about 10 to 15 minutes
so we can walk the track
and i said if it's you
yeah we can walk and we can talk
by the way this guy's name was omar and
he was turkish
and he was a born muslim in prison
so we walked and talked
and subhanallah you know something that
is amazing is
when allah wants to guide somebody
he puts people in our lives or situation
situations in our life
that are exactly what we need to hear
that
call to our souls
and our natural fitrah
so as we walked around the track excuse
me
so as we walked around the track he he
told me
i had always been fascinated with the
universe with
creation with nature you know i'm
norwegian american so i love to hike i
love the mountains i love nature
and the first thing he said to me
is
what do you know about islam
and i said
you're going to have to say that in
english because i don't know what is
islam
islam what is that what how do you say
it in english he said
dude it's islam it's a religion
like you've never heard of islam i said
no
say you know we we talked a little bit
and he said you know isn't it amazing
how allah subhanahu ta'ala our creator
had put the
the sun 93 million miles away from earth
and the moon 200 and 200 000 odd miles
away
and yet
he puts them together out of the
vastness of the whole universe
allah put them together in an eclipse
and i just thought
this guy is deep
this guy is deep he's coming you know
and so
long story short him and i always used
to you know as soon as we came out to
the yard he would look for me and we
would talk we would walk and we would
talk i could notice from my
people
that they were kind of like
what's this
why is this guy hanging out with with
you know uh black people and and and and
this this turkish guy with the long
mustache what's going on with this guy
and people used to hey man
what's going on man what like what's
going on with you why you you know and
so i just told them you know hey
this guy's telling me about islam
you know i'm still a christian i'm you
know whatever
so we used to always talk
and he would ask me about my christian
belief
he destroyed the trinity
very quickly
the sonship of
of jesus
he destroyed all of these concepts
by using the bible and the quran
and that made me mad
because
howard dude i don't i don't even know
you and you're coming with this religion
that i've never heard before
trying to deconstruct
everything that i believed in since i
was a kid
you're trying to break this down
but in my cell
i would think
but he's doing it pretty successfully
it's i mean
which only made me try harder with the
bible to defend the bible and so him and
i would would go back and forth
but every time he would come back with
something that was so beautiful
something which was
irrefutable
that eventually
i really gave up on christianity
so now i was i gave up on christianity
totally and i was looking for
something to replace it because
i am a man who does believe in god i've
never been an atheist
i just need the right channeling
i need something authentic
so he gave me a quran
that was the
maybe a month later he gave me the quran
he said look i'm going to give you a
gift
i'm going to give you this quran
take care of it
and put it in a clean place and don't
read it except if you wash your hands i
was like
okay this is deep this is a this he's
really respecting his book okay
so i opened the quran and the first
surah that i
i opened to
was
and i thought
that's me
i'm the one who was raised upper upper
white you know uh upper class
i'm the one who's been distracted my
whole life
that's me
and so i kept on flipping through and i
read surta al-rahman that's my favorite
surah i read surah al-rahman
the whole of the entirety
and i just thought
like what is what's what's happening in
my heart of this like this beautiful
book that's
you know which one of the favors of your
lord will you deny
which one of the favors are you lord
will you deny which one of the favors of
your lord will you deny
and i said to myself
none of them i have nothing to say i
won't deny anything any of the favors of
allah as a christian i said this to
myself
none of them
the shaytan whispered to me
as i was reading the quran and i went
back to the to the index
and i started looking for names
jesus
moses
abraham jonah and i said oh
i thought this book was going to be
different but it's just like the bible
and if it's just like the bible there's
going to be contradictions as well
you know
but alhamdulillah as as as omar and i
talked
and i and i read the quran and quran
even more it just it just proved itself
even more he was like look bro
this quran is revealed in the language
it stays in the language in which it was
revealed
nobody can change it not even a letter
not even a meaning
it's authenticated and that
put all of my concerns to bed basically
about two months after that and this is
where the real change started happening
so at the moment at that moment i was
i liked islam
i did
i didn't let anybody know that
because
i don't know why but you know i i didn't
let anybody know that
maybe it was pride maybe it was ego i
don't know what it is was
so he came to me in the yard and he said
look man
how about you how about we invite you to
juma
it's happening this friday
you could be there
um you could see everything you could
talk with the other brothers and see how
we do it i said
sure okay
so
i was a christian still
and here i am going to my first jummah
so i show up and by the way it's a
multi-purpose room people ask me was
there a masjid in prison no
it's it's just a multi-purpose room
so the first thing that happens is i go
inside
and i hear the adhan
and the brother was was
the brother was
really making the adhan
and it's the first time that i heard
that then
and and i just stopped
and i just took it all in
and i liken it to
i called it a song i i asked omar what
is this beautiful song that this brother
is singing
he said it's it's not a song
it's he's calling people to people to
prayer
you know
and i thought to myself that's that's
impressive and the adhan just
it hit me man
it really really hit me hard
it's almost as if
i've always heard it
it's as if i heard it
thousands of years ago before i was even
born i don't know how to explain it but
it felt like a homecoming almost
of of the soul of the heart
so he said okay
let me show you how we make hudu
and he started making wudu
and i said why do you why do you make
hudu why why do you do this he said we
do this
before we pray every time we do this
before jummah
because we want to purify ourselves
and i thought
wow
these people call each other the prayer
these people
wash themselves before
they worship god
and christianity
we don't have that you could
you know be intimate with your wife and
go to church like it's all good
not saying that christians are unclean
but i was impressed with with the
respect that they gave through
to the holy place in which they were
going
so that impressed me so the adhan
impressed me the the uh
the uh uulu impressed me so we came into
the main prayer hall
and he said okay check this out
basically what's gonna happen
is
we're going to
sit down in rows
there's going to be the imam in the
front
he's going to give the khutbah he's
going to give a sermon it's just like
sunday church i said okay
and then afterwards he's going to stand
up and
lead the prayer
he's going to recite the quran
and i asked him i said well wait a
minute he's going to like how does he
pray does he open the book and he he
reads it to us or or what
he said
no this this imam that's leading us in
prayer has memorized the quran and he
will just recite it from his memory i
said omar come on
that book that you gave me this stick
he memorized this book come on bro
ridiculous
he said not only not only him
there's
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
muslims that have
memorized the quran
since it was revealed until today it
will be it was it was memorized 1400
years ago it is memorized now it will be
memorized a thousand years from now it
is a preserved book
and i was just like
whoa
whoa
they're calling each other to prayer
they're washing themselves they're
reciting the book the holy book in which
they memorized
wow i was impressed i was impressed big
time
so
the time for prayer came
and they all stood up oh these are these
are big boys these are big boys you know
six foot two
muscle-bound fit guys man
but when they all lined up so omar told
me just just
sit over to the side we're gonna pray
and then afterwards we'll talk but you
know just sit over here
i said okay
fine
so they're all
lined up
imam says
as soon as he said that
i stood up
i'm here for the whole experience i want
to see everything
if i came to juma
it means that i've committed to
taking in the whole experience
so
i went to the first row
beside all the muslims and i saw that
you know these these these men these
lions
as soon as
the imam pronounced allahu akbar
they all became
they all became
became humble in front of their lord
and although omar told me to sit on the
side and wait for them to pray
i went to the front row and i did one of
these
i just uh i wanted to see i was curious
i i looked in the front row
because i wanted to look at their faces
i wanted to see the whole experience
and subhanallah they were so
they were humbled
in front of their lord
but if anybody wants to ask
ali what was what was the point in where
it pushed you over what was the point
where allah
opened your heart
i'll tell you
it wasn't until
all of these muslims and i'm i'm a
christian watching them
it wasn't until i saw
all of these brothers make sujud
that's what did it
that's what did it right there for me
when i saw them going to sejud
altogether
i just
it took my breath away i just
wow
these
i
i have never seen worship of god until
today
they have called each other to the
prayer
they have made wudu they had purified
themselves they had recited the holy
quran
and then they had become humble in their
prayer and put their face on the ground
and complete adoration of their lord
subhana wa ta'ala
oh
islam is irresistible for me at this
point
completely irresistible
i have to have it
and allah open my heart
in that moment
so you know
and so omar
unbeknownst to him he comes up to me and
he says uh
so what'd you think
and i said something out of ignorance
because
like i said i grew up in a white bubble
upper class bubble
and i said omar let me tell you
something man i said come here man i
pulled him to the side
and i said something out of ignorance
i said i don't know if white people
become can become muslim
but i'm not leaving here
until you tell me a way
into islam you have to make an exception
for me
because i'm going to become a muslim
today
and he kind of laughed and all the
brothers were like allahu akbar
subhanallah
so we got in a circle
in october 1991
30 years ago
and i said that
muhammad
and my life has
never been the same since
and i always say that
allah subhanahu ta'ala puts us in
situations
precarious situations and places
so that we can receive islam
and therefore
prison was the best thing that ever
happened in my life
allah says in the quran
had taken that seal from my
heart by just
watching muslims
not only knowing their book
but seeing muslims in action and that's
why i say
the way that we behave within each other
and in the world around non-muslims
is one hundred percent in dawah
so we really need to be on our p's and
q's
watch how we talk to people watch how we
represent islam on a daily basis
and that's not exclusive to non-muslims
how do our kids see us how do our wives
see us how does our family see it how
does our non-muslim
mother and father see
what islam has done in our lives
it's very important
so in a nutshell
that's that's how i became muslim
i saw love bro
it's beautiful
i wanted to
i want to say like i don't know what it
is man i think for
rebirth's
suit out of mind it's just
it hits different and you know a lot
knows best but for some reason every
single reaver that i've talked to that
you know i've watched a video or
something about they always
make reference to surah rahman so
there's got to be something there
yeah agreed
allah
masha allah bro
everybody's looking for that mercy
that's why
we live in a world that
there is no mercy so people are starving
for mercy and so when they read this the
soda it's like
ah it's like drinking taking a cold
drink of water after you've been lost in
the desert all your life yeah you know
yeah i had
uh moved the mic down just a little bit
[Music]
yeah you know better
it's really loud but it's really loud
bro we've had a couple dozen people
you know that rebirth sharing the story
on the channel thus far but i must say
man brother ali's story has been so
captivating i literally felt like i was
in it for the journey yeah yeah
i was gonna say man it's hard to top
that honestly alhamdulillah
subscribe
and that's one of the most powerful
abilities bro and it's beautiful
hearing one something subscribe was so
so
eye-opening allah
and it was basically that
so you know when you guys you know you
get mad and the anger motivates you you
know someone says like oh i know you
couldn't do it it's like you're gonna
see you're gonna say i can do it you
know
anger is not actually the greatest
motivator although it might feel like it
the greatest motivator is actually
gratitude
when you're grateful that's what
motivates you the most so surah
al-rahman is just reminding you of all
the things you need to be grateful for
and the beautiful ayats you recited and
you mentioned
which of the favors of your lord will
you deny
subhanallah at that point you know
everyone's answer should be what your
answer was none
i have nothing to deny i'm nothing to be
ungrateful for subhanallah and it's
really motivating it's really moving and
that's why we're reminded to be grateful
not just to allah but to the people as
the prophet islam he said whoever is not
grateful to people is not grateful to
allah whoever is ungrateful to the
people
is ungrateful to allah
and
subhanallah
we don't have long so i really want to
get more insha allah about this
beautiful story so my first question is
how would you say and i understand it's
going to be a lot but how would you say
islam has changed your life after you
accepted it what changed about you and
your life
what changed me
most i would say
accountability
knowing that
it's not so easy
just to say
jesus died for my sins
i can do whatever i want
no
what i say
what i do in my life
from one moment to the next
is held accountable
on yom al-adhim
i would say accountability
christianity is
go for what you know
make it up as you go along
all of these christians so-called
christians are
all of them much tahidin they open up a
bible and they think yeah i'm not much
to head now i'm going to make a
substitute of the bible and
it has no compass where
islam has
and our prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
has an answer for everything the quran
and the sunnah is the best self-help
book if i could refer to it that way
that's out there it's the best seller
it's the history's best seller the quran
and the sunnah
so that's why i say christians i don't
mean to bust on christians but
they are the most miskeen people on the
planet earth they their book is not
authenticated they have no sunnah at all
they have no
and their akida is
jesus died for your sins
i i don't understand why people are
still christian to this day it amazes me
but i would say that islam
calls
to account everybody personally for what
they do how they act
so
yeah i remember
i remember when i was christian
um i was in my fiance's house
and i remember i had read something
about
um
the time in which jesus had uh
disappeared
and i i i remember correctly they called
this like the the golden years or
something like that where once he came
back then it's like
not he was god supposedly suffolk but
now he was like
the almighty at that point and that's
like
i was trying to look up i was you know
like i'm pretty curious like what
happened during this time like what what
caused them to
get to this state you know the
prophethood that we know of now
yeah and i remember i was in the living
room
just like looking on the the tv they had
one of those smart tvs so i'm just like
looking looking at random youtube videos
seeing if i can find anything looking on
my phone i have the the laptop next to
me i'm like just researching and i was
there for like maybe four or five hours
and like they were trying to get me to
do things like no no like i'm trying to
i'm trying to find something right now i
was like really focused just hyper
focused in
and then i remember her mom came in
after like four or five hours
and she's like what are you doing like
why why have you not you know like done
anything with us you've just been here
and it looks like you haven't made any
progress you're just in the same place
i'm like well i'll tell you what like i
found this out and i'm trying to figure
out like what happened during this
timeframe because i feel like
the insight the value that could come
from this could potentially change
someone's life i mean like if if what
jesus peace be upon him what he went
through allowed him to get to this point
like imagine what that could do for just
a layman just a normal person
and when i told her that she was like oh
why does that matter
i'm like what like how does that not
matter like that's the most important
thing
i don't know man it's just it's like you
said christians they
jesus died for my sins
that's all that matters i don't even do
anything else yeah
it's fun a lot man it's funny i feel
like i have a million questions to ask i
don't even know where to begin uh to be
completely honest
i did want to touch on something that
was mentioned before
um before you told the story if i can
remember it allah
man i remember for a second then it
disappeared yeah i got a question too
bro well you try to remember i go for it
so brother ali
if you don't mind me asking
after you revert it i'm assuming because
you mentioned you've been muslim for 30
years
i i don't assume any of you kids are
over the age of 30.
no so all of them were born into islam
all of them okay so my question to you
is how would you
putting you know guiding them to islam
teaching them islam how would that have
changed had some of them been born
before eurovision
that's a good question that's a
difficult question
i don't think it would be different at
all because i would teach my kids
regardless if they came or they were
born into islam or they weren't it might
be
more difficult but at the same time like
i said
it's all about how if people see the
islam inside of you
you know
like when i was in prison i saw the
islam
of the muslims
you know so i i don't really think it
makes any difference
whether
a child is born in islam or not born in
islam
if allah
wants to guide you
nobody can
nobody can stop it
so this being said like how did you
raise your kids and what advice do you
have to mothers and fathers out here
having been someone that's gone through
the hoops
oh my god
ask ask the
test the belief
of your kids
if their answers are unsatisfactory
it's your
fault
it's your don't blame it on anybody
don't try to drop your kid off at the
saturday you know duksy or madrassa or
whatever
no that's your fault
you are the ones
that you know the mother and the father
that were supposed to raise them
so i always say
the most important thing for me for
beginning muslims or people that are
coming back to islam they're born muslim
rectify your belief
it's all about akida
once you have that straight
then you build up from the floor up
um
be very well versed about who allah
subhanahu ta'ala is
what is impossible for him what is you
know the whole akita
teach your kids akida
i would say to challenge their belief
and ask them why are you a muslim
you're going to get a lot of surprising
answers because you are dead well then
we're back to like the pagan pre-islamic
pagans that say you know we worship
because we we found our fathers doing
this
that's the only reason that they were
worshiping idols is because we found our
fathers doing this this is who we are
but the thing with the thing is when
you're a muslim
and you ask a muslim child why are you
muslim and he's going to say the same
thing
but i'm sorry that's not good enough
because a little boy or a little girl
you know seven years old 12 years old 20
years old
can have nothing in their heart of islam
they're jumping through the hoops so how
do we how do we rectify that this is my
advice
other than challenging the belief of
your
uh kids and if you get an answer which
is unsatisfactory you have to teach them
other than that
something that is vital and not
happening
in some white families african-american
families and immigrant families and all
of our families
is the ability
of out us as parents
to listen to our kids
you have to take their spiritual
temperature
often
you have to be open
to your son or your daughter saying
dad
i don't want to in i don't want to
[Music]
cause you any pain i don't i don't want
to offend you but
i have some doubts about islam
i have a what does this mean i saw this
on the youtube on youtube and on the
internet and i don't understand it
usually our answer is what
a stock for allah how could you what
what do you mean you have doubts in
islam how dare you
okay that's it i'm sending you back
pakistan bangladesh saudi arabia yemen
you're going back home
they have doubts because you didn't
remedy their doubts they have doubts
because you didn't teach them proper
islam it didn't come from them it came
from you
so as parents we really have to be open
to what our kids say
dad why does it say in islam we can't
have girlfriends
do you have the answer
do you have the temperament to be
patient with your kids to answer those
questions
there's going to be a lot of questions
that my kids have asked asked me that
i've just been like
oh my god my kids are growing up i don't
want to deal with this
but hey
welcome to fatherhood
welcome to fatherhood these are your
kids
would you rather them feel more
comfortable speaking to you about real
difficult taboo issues or would you
rather them go to their friends and go
to the internet to get the wrong answer
they trust you
you're the one
you're the one that raised them
you're the one that's supposed to give
them their answers
period
subhanallah you know
that was
exactly what i was going to say when i
said that i had something to mention and
i forgot it that was literally exactly
important to mention so barakallahu may
allah bless you foreign
he mentions
you and your forefathers or he narrates
ibrahim he said i'm saying that to his
his people and his father
you and your forefathers were worshiping
these idols and so on and so forth
but what what would make it different
for a muslim if they said you know what
brother ali mentioned
allah will accept someone's islam based
on their fitra he will accept someone's
islam based on
them being convinced that islam is the
truth on the evidence and having a man
but will allah accept it based on some
kind of speculation or based on hey my
you know family was muslim so now i'm a
muslim
allahu adam
my bad guys time to pray
over there
yeah yeah believe it or not that's
actually just my alarm clock
but no it is coming up soon follow up
so you said before you went to prison
you were doing what you were doing
because you were trying to
just feel something
you felt like you were just
you said
you said spiritually bankrupt you said
another thing as well
but it's for like a better word it's
like you were empty inside you were
trying to feel something
my question to you
is do you feel like
this is the state of every human being
when they don't have allah when they
don't have like that clear course that
clear direction
what a beautiful question
and the answer is yes
especially christians
your average day american
british person european person chinese
whoever
islam is definitely the
only solution
to everyday
islam teaches you how to be a human and
i know that's going to sound
weird or harsh to a lot of non-muslims
watching this but
me being a christian
and now being a muslim for 30 years of
my life
it really does teach you how to
islam is a very human religion
even in fick we have so many
dispensation dispensations that we can
have
uh
to make life easier you know fasting is
is
is not observed by the old man by the
pregnant woman the breastfeeding woman
it's it's
very
human
you get what i'm saying
so
when people
experience islam if they would
experience islam if they would open
their hearts to islam
instead of getting their
information or knowledge from people
like david wood and you know uh
christian prince i didn't want to say
his name cp no jokers like this
they haven't even tasted islam they
haven't even approached islam yet
and that's our job to do that to
you know
give islam to the people
but i think yeah i think people are
really
empty i i often wonder why
people are christian you know but allah
he's he's the one who gives hidayah not
me all we can do is is our best but yeah
people are really
especially
not only christianity or judaism or
islam
you know the media and our schools
are
not teaching spirituality they're
teaching
lower desires given to your lower
desires everything is okay let's
tolerate everything everything goes
but somehow christianity and judaism and
islam is pushed out of the way so
we're really in a strange time
i agree bro i agree 100
and i do think that everyone is empty i
just want to hear your thoughts on it
because
before i came to islam man
um
i was empty
i felt the void
i i was doing anything just to feel
something bro i was jumping out of
planes doing skydiving i was on my
motorcycle going like 150 miles per hour
in like a 25 zone i was over here in my
car
and like you know like when you're about
to turn left like the lights green you
can turn left but you got to wait until
like there's no cars coming i would wait
until the cars were like right there and
then i would go just as fast as possible
to where it's like the cars are right
there about to hit me i did anything
just to feel something bro i would go on
the highway i would get a rental car go
on the highway and just be busting like
a hundred 120 just going
boom just in and out of cars just to
feel something bro i would fight just to
feel something so i was like this is why
i asked man cause
it's interesting to see like
when someone else says like yo yeah i
did something very similar
because i feel empty
it's almost like the heart is rebelling
the heart is it's not
getting what it's what it wants so it's
trying to get that
that uh
your heart pumping you know when you're
doing 130 on a motorcycle you know just
lay down and going through the gears
yeah
it's stressing out it's like
okay it's got life has got to be more
than this come on
yeah that's true totally true yeah
let me miss him
it's crazy
surrounded man yo i feel like i don't
know if uh i'm sure the other two
brothers can agree but i feel like i
could talk to you all day man we
definitely have to get you back on the
podcast guys if you made it this far
smash that like button go over to
youtube search up maliki click links in
the description down below subscribe
show the brother some love he deserves
it and he's doing wonderful work so may
allah bless you for that and continue to
add us all to the straight path i mean
bro we got jumbo coming up so i say we
wrap this up
yeah all right let's do it
allah bless everyone who attended and
bless brother ali for the beautiful
story
honestly that impacted me more than
words can explain
alhamdulillah
thanks for having me and thanks for the
opportunity i'm at the servers of the
ummah anytime anywhere
alhamdulillah all this from allah
and with that being said
yes
[Music]
foreign